Лікар-протезист з України і підприємець з Білорусі
роблять протези для українських військових.
Вони створили у США благодійну платформу Protez Foundation,
яка допомагає українцям, які втратили кінцівки через війну.
Приїхавши в Америку, я розумів, що мені буде дуже важко
стати хірургом тут. Мені сподобалося протезування.
Я вивчився тут, закінчив Гарвардський університет
за спеціальністю протезування та ортезування.
Закінчивши його, я почав працювати,
приблизно 15 років працюю в протезуванні.
І завжди у мене в серці було бажання допомагати людям.
Я завжди допомагав людям з Африки, Південної Америки, України.
А Юрій Арошидзе переїхав до США із Білорусі кілька років тому.
Тут від початку повномасштабної війни в Україні почав
допомагати українським біженцям, а потім - військовим.
Коли почалася війна, звичайно, усі не могли просто так дивитися на війну,
усі хотіли щось робити, як і ми. Але у нас була історія
ще до війни, коли до нас приїхав хлопець Богдан із Дніпра,
молодий пастор церкви. У нього ампутація в дитинстві відбулася,
він потрапив під трамвай. Він приїхав сюди, жив у мене,
і я возив його до лікаря на протезування.
Яків зробив йому безкоштовне протезування,
так ми з ним і познайомилися. Потім, коли почалася війна,
ми займалися нашими емігрантами, українцями,
які приїжджали сюди, допомагали різними способами,
у нас був невеликий штаб. І в один момент виникла ідея,
так, як ми зробили протез для Богдана, чому не можемо
протезувати, допомагати солдатам нашим?
Їхня благодійна платформа працює у Міннеаполісі з травня 2022 року.
Протези вже отримали близько пів сотні осіб:
кілька дітей, сімей пара з Бучі. Решта пацієнтів - військові ЗСУ.
Саме українським захисникам надається першочергова допомога.
Поза чергою також діти. А в списку очікування - наразі понад 700 людей.
Ми поділили весь проєкт на дві частини:
медичну та організаційну. Медичною у нас Яків займається повністю:
це закупівля, встановлення протезів. У нас є своя клініка з лабораторією,
де Яків робить протези всім за один день.
Тобто до нас приїжджає група солдатів, вони за один день
отримують протези і вже ввечері ходять на протезах.
Пацієнти проводять у США три з половиною тижні
для протезування та реабілітації. Протезування однієї людини
коштує приблизно 15 тисяч доларів.
Ми витрачаємо всього 800 доларів для того, щоб солдати
прилетіли сюди. Але що ми маємо за ці 800 доларів?
Ми за 800 доларів маємо те, що пацієнти, перебуваючи в Україні
і відлітаючи в Америку, відкривають для себе новий світ.
Для них це дуже класна реабілітація - те, що вони зі свого середовища
сирен, вибухів та всього іншого переміщуються сюди,
де є нова країна.
Більшість солдатів взагалі за кордоном ніколи не були.
В Америці рівень вдячності до солдатів, ви знаєте, дуже великий.
Їм скрізь дякують за службу, неважливо,
що це українські військові, вони дуже дякують, підходять,
за них платять у всіх ресторанах, куди ми не підемо - за них всі платять.
Вони відчувають тут величезну любов і підтримку спільноти.
Проєкт об'єднав близько 150 волонтерів, задіяних у різних сферах
- харчування, житло, транспорт, а також волонтери-медики.
Більшість їхніх пацієнтів - українські військові, але є й цивільні та діти.
Саша грав у дворі, коли влучила ракета і осколками
йому дуже поранило ногу.
Він каже: "Мене оглушило, я почав бігти в будинок.
Чомусь моя ніжка перестала слухати мене".
Це було важко чути від дитини, якій жити і жити,
а тут він  втратив ногу.
Я встановив йому протез вище коліна.
Він завжди питає: "А можна мені ще спортивну стопу,
а можна, щоб я міг бігати?"
І, ви знаєте, я тепер Саші збираю гроші, щоб зробити йому біговий
протез, в якому йде спеціальне коліно, спеціальна стопа.
Не просто спортивна стопа, а бігова.
Protez Foundation існує на пожертвування.
Донатить, як правило, велика кількість людей
невеликими сумами - по 20-50 доларів.
Засновники проєкту кажуть, що найбільше їх захоплює мотивація
пацієнтів, які хочуть якомога швидше встати на ноги
і повернутися в Україну.
Особливо мене здивував Олег з Бучі.
Коли був напад саме на Бучу, то він постраждав, втратив руку.
І я прошу його, щоб він довше залишився тут,
щоб я закінчив протезування.
Він каже: "Яків, будь ласка, швидше зробіть,
я повинен їхати, на мене чекає місто, нам потрібно відновлюватися.
У нас техніка вкрадена, у нас місто завмерло.
Ми маємо повернути місто до нормального життя".
Він може залишитися в Америці, він може залишитися в Європі,
у нього був дозвіл на проживання в Іспанії,
куди він потрапив відразу після ампутації.
Але він хоче повернутися та допомогти Україні.
І ви знаєте, я подумав тоді: я маю зробити все максимально можливе,
щоб ці українці мали бажання повернутися
і продовжувати боротися за кращу Україну.